dann haben wir ja im grunde fragen die
jeden interessieren dazu kommt noch dass
wir es mit mutierten viren zu tun haben
das heißt dass die gefährlichkeit der
aggressivität des virus noch einmal
zunehmen könnte und man darf nicht
vergessen unsere diskussion findet ja
nicht im normalen leben statt sondern
unsere diskussion findet in einer umwelt
statt und in einem umfeld in dem wir im
lockdown sitzen in den schulen und kitas
nicht normal funktionieren indem die
geschäfte geschlossen sind die kultur
veranstaltungen nicht stattfinden
reisen nicht möglich sind bürgerinnen
und bürger sich beschränken müssen
und wir wissen alle dass impfen ist ein
großer teil des weges aus der pandemie
und deshalb natürlich auch diese
dringlichkeit
dabei geht es glaube ich um drei fragen
die wir heute auch in verschiedenen
formaten dann besprochen haben einmal
kommen die mengen die zugesagt wurden
wirklich gibt es da verlässlichkeit
zweitens treibt uns natürlich um wie
sieht der vergleich mit anderen ländern
aus man hört aus israel man hört aus den
vereinigten staaten von amerika aus
großbritannien dieses und jenes dazu
waren ja auch die vertreter der
europäischen kommission da und was
wollen wir bei unserem vorgehen wie wir
es jetzt praktizieren beibehalten und
was wollen wir ändern oder ergänzen und
zu diesen drei fragen möchte ich
stellung nehmen erstens wir haben
berechenbarkeit für die lieferungen der
unternehmen für die verschiedenen
quartale dieses jahres
und da müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen
den zusagen derer die bereits eine
zulassung haben das sind bei und ex
kaiser moderner und astrazeneca und es
gibt zwei weitere impfstoffhersteller
die heute auch am gespräch teilgenommen
haben
johnson & johnson und kühe weg die beide
zwar von antragstellungen auf zulassung
im zweiten quartal oder anfang des
dritten quartals ausgehen
die aber noch keine zulassung haben dass
deren liefermengen sind schon im raum
die produzieren ja auch vor dafür haben
geld bekommen von der europäischen
kommission also auch vom deutschen
steuerzahler aber auch die können wir
noch nicht abschließend rechnen
das heißt wir haben im grunde ist immer
mit einer situation zu tun wo wir eine
minimalvariante haben auf die wir jetzt
relativ gut rechnen können und eine
maximalvariante wenn alle eine zulassung
bekommen
in beiden varianten und die zahlen wären
noch mal vom gesundheitsministerium auch
haus gegeben falls ihnen noch nicht
vorliegen sollten
kann man sagen dass unsere aussage dass
wir bis ende des dritten quartals also
bis ende des sommers den menschen jedem
bürger einen impf angebot machen können
dass wir diese aussage aufrechterhalten
können allerdings haben uns die
hersteller heute auch gesagt es kann
immer wieder in der produktion etwas
auftreten sie alle haben damit auch noch
keine erfahrung was sie nicht
voraussehen aber ich glaube die zahlen
im großen ganzen
für die quartale haben schon eine große
relevanz
wir müssen wir haben etwa neun millionen
kinder in deutschland für die ist ja der
impfstoff nicht zugelassen moderner ist
glaube ich ab 16 zugelassen bei uns ab
und ansonsten gibt es für kinder noch
keine zugelassenen impfstoffe das wird
auch erst in den frühestens in den
sommermonaten kommen
das heißt bei 83 millionen einwohnern
dann brauchen wir im grunde für 73
millionen menschen ungefähr 1
impfangebot und wenn man die einzelnen
quartalzahlen sich anschaut dann kann
selbst wenn johnson & johnson und kühe
weckt keine zulassung bekommen
dieses angebot für jeden gemacht werden
nach den jetzt vorliegenden zahlen
sollten die anderen
denn auch eine zulassung bekommen dann
haben wir sogar ein größeres angebot
wir haben dann die frage zu beantworten
wie es das im vergleich mit anderen
ländern
und daran gehörte natürlich darüber
gesprochen was sind die
produktionsstandorte aus denen heraus
europa beliefert wird
und dann muss man sehen dass die
vereinigten staaten von amerika durch
ihren projekt eine situation haben wo
sie im grunde kaum an drittstaaten
exportieren
das heißt also die im vorstellung mit
ihren im standorten im grunde für den
eigenen bedarf machen europa ist damit
auch auf seine standorte zurückverwiesen
und diese standorte sind da
glücklicherweise können wir uns freuen
es werden auch immer mehr
kooperationsangebote eingegangen wie
heute koenig & bauer das wird aber erst
im dritten oder vierten quartal oder ist
anfangs 22 wichtig aber europa hat nicht
unendlich viele solcher standorte das
heißt wir sind mit dem
produktionskapazitäten begrenzt
insbesondere jetzt im ersten und zweiten
quartal wird es schon deutlich besser
aber im ersten quartal
zweitens in die europäische union hat
sich nicht für note zu lassen
entschieden wir wissen großbritannien
zum beispiel hat binnen 24 stunden
astrazeneca zugelassen
ich finde aus guten gründen es geht hier
nämlich auch um vertrauen hat die
europäische union sich die zulassung der
ema die zulassung der ema gehalten und
das ist keine not zulassung sonst eine
vorläufige zulassung hat also eine
andere qualität
drittens wir haben uns entschieden und
das hat uns heute vertreter der der chef
der ständigen impfkommission noch einmal
gesagt die zweite impfung geben von der
ema angegebenen intervall zu geben
das heißt nach einer bestimmten wochen
zahl gibt es die zweite impfung es wird
ja auch diskutiert kann weil es
auch davon abweichen wir haben uns zu
dieser abweichung bisher nicht
entschieden weil wir glauben wir sollten
auf fachlicher grundlage arbeiten dann
gibt es länder da nenne ich israel die
in ganz anderer weise auch mit daten
umgehen digitalisierung betreiben das
etwas wo datenschutz eine große rolle
spielt dieses werden wir sicherlich in
den nächsten jahren immer wieder
diskutieren
ich persönlich das ist so ähnlich wie
bei der app bin der meinung dass wir
möglichst viele vertrauenswürdige gesten
machen damit die menschen auch vertrauen
zu dem impfen haben und hier den
datenschutz sehr hoch halten und
letztens wir haben die europäische union
hat zum teil auch sehr lange verhandelt
weil es um haftungsfragen ging und die
gesamte haftung auf die politische ebene
zu nehmen und nicht ein stück bei den
herstellern zu lassen das ist eine
entscheidung bei der sich die
europäische kommission unterstütze dass
man um diese haftungsfragen lange auch
gerungen hat denn wenn etwas passieren
würde dann würde das in jedenfalls bei
uns in deutschland aber auch in vielen
europäischen ländern eine sehr große
bedeutung haben
deshalb ist der weg an einigen stellen
langsamer gewesen das ist richtig aber
ich finde es gibt auch gute gründe dafür
dass er langsamer war wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren